the jurogan experience
so to go back to when you when we met i
think i was sober already i think it was
like newly sober just to circle back to
that and uh anyone wondering when i
actually did get sober sober sober it
was when i was 35 so like eight years
ago
and but it was like a long
time coming i from the i when i was
first in rehab i was 19
and then
from 20 to 35 it was like coke and molly
and weed and yeah drinking whew
it was well i i i lived my life to the
fullest
but i probably should have died
i mean it's a miracle i didn't die did
you ever odd so right before i got sober
i was doing la tamale at um coachella
which sounds as disgusting as you just
heard it
but wait it gets grosser
[Laughter]
and um
the
i was probably dehydrated because i
don't think i had any water in like two
days and i was like doing molly during
the day and doing blow at night and
drinking through the whole thing and i
was really obsessed with this like
blueberry red bull that they had i
[ __ ] hate red bull but i was just
drinking it with and it was like laced
with molly or whatever so that was like
and then we were in vip this is why i'm
saying it's gonna get grosser guys so
bear with me and we're walking
and i went down like i just blacked out
i was like i looked at my friend and i
was like i am [ __ ] roll and that's
the last thing i remember
and i just went down like a like just a
a bowling pin and apparently into some
australian chicks of all things
and i wake up come too and there's like
four cops standing around me and they're
like what day is it
and i somehow knew it was sunday and i
mean you've been to festivals you have
no idea what day it is even if you're
sober like or what time it is right and
i knew what time it was like my brain
got a hard reset i really i really think
my brain was like
we're shutting it down like we need to
reset some files
we
reboot i came to i was like freezing
cold
and the australians were like you have
the worst friends you have the worst
friends the worst friends because they
weren't too they were like ah she'll be
fine
one of my friends is one of my best
friends from high school and she and i
she was around during the heroin days
and we used to go to raves together and
do like speed
and so we had been through a lot and she
was like ah she's taking a disco nap and
they were like they called him a disco
nap
[Laughter]
a disco now friend girl did a difference
oh my god you have horrible friends i
was like that is a very funny statement
a disco nap yeah she's taking a disco
nap
that's a good phrase oh yeah i like that
phrase so i came i came to luckily but
it was like a bit of a wake-up call and
i wasn't young i was like about to be 35
or maybe i already was 35 like
it was a little bit old to be
blacking out going down and vip
like oh just so gross it was so gross i
mean pitiful demoralization what the
[ __ ] do you present you you're taking a
disco nap
they're like ah she's fine let's keep
partying then i found a yankees hat and
i put it on and that's when i knew it's
time to get sober
so where did you go did you go to get
sober on did you do it on your own yeah
i just so i had tried everything like
every i mean i was i was the classic
like only drink only drink booze only
drink alone only drink with friends only
i did the whole like marijuana
maintenance only smoke weed i got
certified in yoga become a yoga
instructor i
went to therapy literally anything other
than
12 step because i had been in 12 step
when i was 19 20 that first time and i
hated it
because i couldn't drink
at all and i couldn't do anything
and i just i came up with a big you know
i i came up with a big case against 12
step i was like it's fear based and blah
blah and all the god stuff and i was off
and running and
i was out my first husband and i were
raging alcoholics were in the restaurant
and just i was in the restaurant
industry for a long time in my life that
industry is riddled with alcoholism and
drugs and partying
and so
i was just around it too all the time
and then
um around 35 after that coachella that
summer i just got back from traveling
around the world for like two years i
was very lost i was in la and i didn't
know what i was doing anymore i felt
confused i went back east worked in a
restaurant where i had been
and it was like this whole i felt
immediately into the rut i was like
sleeping with the same douchebags i
slept with when i had been there like
seven years before
having doing tons of drugs burning
bridges with my family and i was coming
back to la
after just my sister wouldn't let me
stay with her
and rightfully and i was a mess and i
was coming back and i was like i'm gonna
cop heroin and kill myself basically i
was just so
internally it was not necessarily like
many of my rock bottoms were actually
physical or my first one i lost
everything
this was more emotional
and
um yeah i was i went for a hike i went
up to like temescal because i was like
well before i cop heroin i should
maybe pause and go for a hike and
sometime on that hike i decided to go to
a meeting that night because i'd done an
experimental year of sobriety in like
2010. what was it about the hike that
i was sweating and my i was like
sweating out i was just toxic i could
feel how toxic i was i could smell how
toxic i was
what did it smell like oh like chemicals
chemicals and
blow and probably like baby powder i
mean you know like
everything just booze and and
i'd been smoking a lot of weed to try
and chemically balance all of it and i
ended up
getting to the top and something it was
like they call it like it was like a
window of grace i don't know it was like
one small window of willingness i don't
i don't know of grace
yeah it was like they're they say there
are these kind of like
opportunities where you can walk through
a like door of willingness if you're
you're really
at rock bottom and trying to get and i
made i've joked about this before i made
alcoholism look amazing like i i had a
lot of
fun i was i was kill i was like from the
outside it looked okay it was just
internally i felt like i was rotting to
the core and i also couldn't really get
out of my own way
and so i went to a meeting and i didn't
even i wasn't like i'm getting sober i
just didn't know what else to do
and i was miserable i mean i was [ __ ]
miserable the first two years of my
sobriety but it was better than feeling
like i wanted to kill myself and so i
just kept walking through it
and
doing what they told me to do they're
like get a stupid job so i was waiting
tables and like why they said you get a
stupid job they're just you know a lot
of times you have this kind of idea of
being a big shot or not that i did at
all i was still waiting tables and like
broke all the time but it's really just
this idea of like being a worker among
workers like put yourself in a get a day
job so you can pay your bills and not be
dependent and struggling
and
put yourself in uh because sometimes
it's like people who come from you know
finance or whatever they were big shots
and then they kind of lose everything
and so then they tell them to get a job
everyone knows themselves well yeah and
just for just for consistency and to be
responsible and to have to show up and
i mean i really realized
i started drinking when i was 12. and
pretty holy alcoholically by the time i
was 15.
and i were [ __ ] 12. yeah i was young
i mean nobody was paying attention no
and my parents got divorced right around
that age
and
um yeah i started i was off to the races
and then it was just by the time i was
19 i was in
it it made a lot of sense and
i was in rehab for heroin and then
got off that but that kind of not being
i use that as an excuse to be like oh
i'm not an addict because i'm not doing
heroin anymore so i use that to stay out
for a long time as an excuse of like
well as long as i'm not doing heroin
because anyone would get addicted to
that
and so yeah i mean it was a long long
journey to sobriety and then i i was
very miserable and somehow and then
around two years like
the rubber just started meeting the road
i got my first column at playboy i sold
my first
um
freelance writing piece i started
doing you have so much energy when you
get sober for somebody like me who is
wasting a lot of it just drinking and
partying
that i just had to do a lot of different
things and i couldn't really
deny that my quality of life improving
drastically and starting to do things
that i'd always wanted to do like be a
paid writer it didn't seem like an
accident that it was a couple of years
after i had been sober that these things
started happening and so while it was
happening did you follow any protocol
did you like did you follow any advice
from books i was in 12-step like full-on
and in
but what what what didn't you like about
that what didn't you like about the 12
step when i first left the 12 steps or
just when i was just in general um
well i have you know i had a lot of
reason to think that abstinence isn't
the only way which they found isn't for
everybody
uh it is for me because there's no
middle ground with subs i i started
smoking cigarettes in sobriety this is a
perfect example of how there's like no
mid-ground and i was so mad because i
quit everything and i started smoking
cigarettes in 2015
and i was i had one cigarette at a
meeting and i was like all right i'll
have a cigarette and then i was off to
the [ __ ] races smoking pack a day
within like weeks i'm like if this is
any example of what i'll be like with
booze or anything i just know there's no
i do not some people can be moderate
they have that ability
and i envy the [ __ ]
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify